WE’LL CHECK WITH OUR SOURCES
ABOUT OF THAT TO SEE IF THEY
CAN GET YOU A HEADS-UP.
MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TURNING UP THE PRESSURE AS HE
CALLED FOR LARGER DIRECT
PAYMENTS TO AMERICANS.
IN A TWEET HE SAYS, WHY WOULD
POLITICIANS NOT WANT TO GIVE
PEOPLE $2,000 RATHER THAN 600,
TONY KATZ, GOOD TO SEE SEE YOU
MY FRIEND.
WHERE IS THIS MONEY COMING
FROM?
>> I THINK IT’S STILL COMING
FROM CHINA AND WHERE IS IT
COMING FROM?
WHERE IS THE NEED?
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT WRONG IT’S
COMING FROM CHINA, BUT SHUTTING
DOWN BUSINESSES IN HAPHAZARD
AND NONSCIENTIFIC WAY AND
CAUSING DISASTER.
600, WHEN YOU SEE THE PLACES
THAT THEY HAVE MONEY EARMARKED
FOR, AND FOLKS FROM THE COAST
TO THE HEART OF THE NATION,
THAT SOUNDS NORMAL, THAT YOU’RE
SENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
THE EGYPTIAN MILITARY AND
NOTHING WRONG WITH WORKING WITH
THE EGYPTIAN MILITARY.
THERE’S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE AMERICANS
THAT ARE TOLD THEY CAN’T GO TO
WORK AND CAN’T FEED LAYER
FAMILIES, THAT’S THE ISSUE.
LELAND: I HAD A PROFESSOR IN
COLLEGE THAT TALKED ABOUT SEE
SAW AND WHAT YOU CAN DO AND
WANT TO DO AND WHEN THINGS ARE
TOO FAR OUT OF WHACK, THEY
START TO FALL APART.
CONGRESS TOOK SIX MONTHS TO GO
HERB --
THEY TOOK SIX MONTHS TO
NEGOTIATE THIS.
AND THEY’RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
FOREIGN AID?
>> NO, IT TOOK MONTHS FOR NANCY
PELOSI TO WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THEY DIDN’T WANT TO
GIVE ANY POLITICAL WIND TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE COULD HAVE HAD HELP MONTHS
AGO, BUT NANCY PELOSI REFUSED.
LELAND: THERE MAY BE THE
POLITICAL FACTS ON THE GROUND
AND THEN THERE’S THE OPTICS.
IF THE PRESIDENT IS PUTTING
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE IN
THE POSITION OF SAYING NO,
WHICH IT SEEMS AS THOUGH MANY
OF THEM ARE AND FOR THAT
MATTER, REPUBLICANS IN THE
HOUSE BECAUSE THAT DID NOT PASS
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT ON
CHRISTMAS EVE, THAT’S A TRICKY
PLACE FOR REPUBLICANS, ISN’T
IT?
>> WELL, THE IDEA THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PUT
REPUBLICANS IN A TRICKY SPOT
BEFORE ISN’T ANYTHING NEWS.
LELAND: FAIR, LET’S GET TO THIS
POINT.
SPEAKING OF A TRICKY PLACE,
YOU’VE GOT REPUBLICANS ON THE
TRAIL IN GEORGIA.
TAKE A LISTEN TO KELLY
LOEFFLER.
>> WHAT DAVID PERDUE AND I HAVE
HAVE BEEN DOING IS FIGHTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY GEORGIAN
CAN LIVE THE AMERICAN DREAM.
LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE’RE
OUTSIDERS AND I’LL NEVER BRING
WASHINGTON TO GEORGIA, I’M
TAKING GEORGIA TO WASHINGTON.
>> THE WHOLE STUMP SPEECH NEVER
ONCE DID SHE TALK ABOUT THE
COVID RELIEF AND STIMULUS BILL.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
PERSON WHO RAN AGAINST HERE IN
THE SPECIAL ELECTION, DOUG
COLLINS, HE VOTED FOR RELIEF
AND NEVER HAS BEEN THERE MORE
OF A SUPPORTER FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
AND GEORGIA, WHAT IT SAYS TO
THE RUNOFF ELECTION.
THE IDEA IS THAT THIS ONE STORY
RUNS BIG IN IN ELECTION, THAT’S
NOT TRUE.
EVEN IF YOU LOOK AT THE ATLANTA
CONSTITUTION, THERE’S A STORY
AND IT’S NOT EVEN A HEADLINE
STORY.
WHERE I FILL IN, THEY’RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THIS, IT’S A
BELTWAY CONCOCTION THAN REAL
LIFE.
LELAND: IT BECOMES REAL LIFE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEEDS THE 600 OR $2,000.
AND THE EVICTION MORATORIUM.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHEN I SAY I’M